- If you came to my house,
we wouldn't have mashed potatoes.
- I bestow the pardon on Mr. Jon Gruden,
yes, I will.
- Thank God you gave
$71 million to Alex Smith.
♪♪♪
- What up, everybody?
Welcome to "Simms & Lefkoe."
It is the wonderful
Thanksgiving edition.
Simms, you're practically family
at this point.
- Oh, Happy Thanksgiving, Lefkoe.
- What did you bring?
- I brought nothing.
- Awesome.
I brought the turkey.
- Oh, that's great.
I'm not eating it.
- Are you a leg or a wing guy?
- Uh, I'm a breast guy.
- OK.
- A leg and a wing is
the same thing, but—
- No, it's not.
The leg is that,
and the wing is that.
- I mean, they're
basically the same piece of meat.
- It's white meat and dark meat.
- Is it, really?
- This is a meaningless debate
that we will figure out later.
But right now it is time
to do our pardons.
You've seen presidential pardons
where they forgive the turkey
and let it live another day.
We have some people in the NFL
that may need to be pardoned.
First one up—
oh, look at this turkey.
Jon Gruden.
- Oh!
-Are you willing to pardon Jon
Gruden for trading Khalil Mack
and leading to what we're seeing
right now in Oakland?
- I bestow the pardon
on Mr. Jon Gruden.
- Wow.
- Yes, I will.
I will give him the pardon
because I think
there was more in play
with the Khalil Mack situation
than what we know.
I do think there was
some financial issues.
- The whole story
hasn't come out yet.
- It has not all come out.
- Mark Davis' checks are
bouncing, is what you're saying.
- Exactly right.
Well, he's had a few issues.
We know that, but I'm giving him
the pardon for Khalil Mack.
- OK. Man, he's so
good, Khalil Mack.
- Yeah.
- It's hard to give him
that pardon.
We got a double turkey here—
- Oh gosh.
- So you can pardon one,
you can pardon both.
On the right, Ty Montgomery,
his fumble in the Rams game.
Mike McCarthy, punting
4th-and-2 against the Seahawks.
Both of these turkeys
prevented us from seeing Rodgers
possibly going the length
of the field.
- Cook 'em.
Well-done.
- Both of 'em?
- Both of 'em.
I mean, put one in the fryer
and the other one in the oven
and make sure they're well-done.
Yeah, they're cooked.
- Just keep 'em juicy.
- There's no excuse
for Ty Montgomery bringing
the ball out in that situation
and cheating all of us
including his own team,
the Packers
and not giving Aaron Rodgers
a chance to win it.
And then Mike McCarthy
with two of your best
defensive players not healthy—
- And you just let up drives
of 77 and 75 yards.
- And you think now
you're gonna stop them?
- Yeah.
- No, sorry.
Into the fryer.
- I got one more for you.
- OK.
- This is Week 2—
- Ooh.
- When, after the Jaguars
beat the Patriots—
I have a clip for this turkey.
- Oh, thank you.
- Chalk it up.
They're gonna win the Super Bowl.
- [Laughing]
- That was you talking
about the Jaguars
with their win
over the Patriots.
- Ohhh.
I am going to say,
in your defense—
- Yeah?
- I'm gonna pardon this turkey.
One, because "Blank & Lefkoe"
doesn't have a cachet to it.
- OK, thank you.
- But I'll be honest.
When the Jaguars beat the crap
out of the Patriots
it wasn't even
that hot of a take.
- No.
- But, boy, have they fallen off.
- No, how dare I have faith in
Blake Bortles and that offense.
- Seriously.
- What was I thinking?
- You're gonna stand
for anything.
You should've known that was coming.
- Right? I know, I know.
They have totally fallen off.
Thanks for giving me the pardon.
- Would you pardon yourself?
- Yeah, I would pardon myself.
I would. Yes, I would.
Thank you.
Can't be right
about everything.
- You can't. Blake Bortles is not
really a meaningless debate.
We know what side you're on.
- Yeah.
But we've been having
a meaningless debate
right here
in the Bleacher Report office
that you can bring
to your Thanksgiving dinner.
It's about sides, and we had
to ask Landon Collins
"Mac and cheese
or mashed potatoes?"
- Dun-dun-dun!
Mac and cheese
or mashed potatoes?
I'm gonna go to Simms first.
- Well, it's mashed
potatoes for me.
- It's mashed potatoes?
- Yeah.
- I'm Southern,
so it's mac and cheese.
- I want you to understand
this is a cultural divide.
- It is.
- Do you even have mashed potatoes
at Thanksgiving? Be honest.
- Not that I recall.
- Not even at the table?
- I don't think so.
- Do you ever have mac and cheese
at your Thanksgiving table?
- Not really.
- I'm fascinated by this
because I love mac and cheese
but to me, Thanksgiving
with the turkey and the gravy
on top of the mashed potatoes
I couldn't fathom
it not being at a table.
- I agree.
- Correct, correct.
- But what do you think?
- I feel that. I feel that.
I like that combination
of how you did that
but mac and cheese
has to be there.
- OK.
- If Landon Collins came to Adam
Lefkoe's Thanksgiving dinner
and I didn't have mac
and cheese, would you be upset?
- No, I wouldn't be upset.
That's just how you have
your household
cuz if you came to my house
we wouldn't have
mashed potatoes.
- Right.
Do you like mashed potatoes?
- Yeah, I love mashed potatoes.
- OK.
- Would you be upset?
- A little.
- I think I would too.
- Would it show?
Would y'all show
your aggression?
- I would, like, pause.
Like, I'd be scooping—
I'd be like
"Green beans?
All right, fine."
- I have no filter, Landon.
I'd be, like, to your whole
family—I'd be like
"No mashed potatoes?
What's goin' on here?"
Like, I'd say it with love.
- Mac and cheese gotta be there.
- I'm Stefon Diggs
and you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
- Hello, and welcome to the
greatest stadium ever invented.
It is Jerry's World
in beautiful Arlington, Texas.
I am Adam Lefkoe, your trusted
Dallas Cowboys homer reporter
and let's welcome in
one of the Simms.
Haven't really taken a chance
to get the name.
- Yeah, I'm Chris.
Thanks.
- Good to meet you.
And he's representing
the Washington Red—
I better not.
- Oh, you mean the team
that's winning
atop the NFC East right now.
How are you doing
in Second Placeville?
- Well, we've won two in a row-
- Whoaaa.
- And technically we're the
favorites to win this division, Chris.
- Oh, whoa, whoop-de-do.
OK, yeah, we lost Alex Smith.
His leg broke like a turkey
wishbone, but we'll be OK.
Colt McCoy's here
to save the day.
He's actually every bit as good
as Alex Smith, if not better.
- Wow, then thank God you gave
$71 million to Alex Smith.
By the way, that was
in guaranteed money.
The future seems bleak, Chris.
- Oh, you shouldn't talk
about the future, buddy.
It sounds like you're about
to back up the ol' truck
to give $75 million
to Dak Prescott.
Good luck with that one.
You guys should be gettin' that
sixth Super Bowl anytime soon.
- It's a Brinks truck,
and I don't know
if I should be listening to
personnel decisions from a man
that let Sean McVay walk
and made Jay Gruden the coach.
By the way, Jay Gruden
is the other Gruden
the one people really aren't
that interested in.
- You had to bring up
Sean McVay, huh?
- Have you heard about
our season ticket scandal?
- I did.
- Have you heard about
our season ticket scandal?
- I did.
- Man, I mean, just pile on.
- What about the parking one?
That was bad, or Brandon Lloyd
or Antwaan Randle El.
- Gosh.
- Those signings were great.
- McNabb, Deion Sanders or—
- Albert Haynesworth.
- Wow.
Let's just know this.
When we eventually win
the division—
- Yes.
- I make a promise to you
that we're gonna lose that first
round of the playoffs
because, well, we're average
as f--k.
- [Laughing]
Football in 2018,
this year especially
has been defined
by the pass.
We're seeing quarterbacks
destroying records.
But we're also seeing
a number of teams
protect their quarterback really well.
- Yeah, right.
You study the film every week,
all the teams, and I thought
it would be cool to do the top
five offensive lines in the NFL.
- Seems fitting.
- And No. 1 may surprise people.
- For Thanksgiving, I mean,
the big boys
the big fatties,
nobody's gonna eat more turkey
than them this week,
I guarantee it.
- I hope not.
I might eat just as much.
Your No. 5 offensive line
is who?
- The Dallas Cowboys.
- They've fallen to 5?
- They have fallen to 5.
They're still awesome.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean, they're capable
of dominating
in the run game
and doing things like that.
- Ever since Marc Colombo
took over that position group-
- Been so much better.
- They've moved themselves
up to 5, I feel like.
- They have, right.
No. 4, a surprise
team out west.
- Yeah, I mean,
the Los Angeles Chargers.
I mean, look what
they're doing this year.
They pass-protect Philip Rivers
phenomenal.
They have a run game that's very
multiple with Anthony Lynn's
run game genius behind it
but pull guards, inside,
outside, zone.
They can do everything.
It's a very good group.
- No. 3, a lotta people
might have this offensive line
at No. 1.
- Yeah.
The Indianapolis Colts are
your No. 3 team O-line.
- Yes, they're No. 3. Yes, I mean,
it hasn't been the whole season.
It's really just come together.
It's young guys,
but this is, like
one of the most promising groups
for the future.
- They could be No. 1
for a long time.
by the end of the season
if they continue to just keep
Andrew Luck clean
and blow people off the line
of scrimmage in the run game.
No. 2, often forgot about.
- Yes!
- The Pittsburgh Steelers.
Nobody ever talks about their
offensive line being one of the best.
- This unit has been together
for so long.
- Right. Opening up holes
for Le'Veon Bell, or James Conner
we're seeing this year.
- Right.
- Keeping people off Big Ben.
Doesn't matter if it's the Jaguars
the Ravens,
whoever it may be.
He seems to have time every week
to let these aggressive downfield
passes kind of, uh, happen.
- Develop.
- "Develop" is the word
I was looking for.
- Gotcha, pal.
I protect you—
- Thanks, man, appreciate it.
- Kind of like your offensive line,
and I'm about the same size.
- Your No. 1 offensive line
you've been talking about
this line for two years—
- Yeah.
- And they're finally
getting some respect.
- Yes, the New Orleans Saints
is the best O-line
in all of football,
whether that's pass-protecting
whether that's big Andrus Peat
pullin' his big butt and legs
that look like they're filled
with turkey and gravy
around the edge to trap people.
You know what else
they're awesome at?
Getting out in the open
in screen game.
That's another huge part
of the Sean Payton offense.
- Sure.
That's another huge part
of the Sean Payton offense.
- Sure.
But everything
that they do on offense
is because
of their O-line's dominance.
- And then when you combine that
with how quickly Drew
can get the ball out.
- Right, Kamara, Ingram—
- Oh man.
- All those things
that are added to it
yes, that makes them
almost unstoppable.
- I'm curious what you guys
think.
Let us know.
Comment section below.
Do you agree with Simms'
O-line ranking?
I'm not gonna protect you here.
I'm gonna sic you
to the comments section
and see what they think.
- Oh no.
- Yeah, I know you're really
afraid of the comments.
-Not the comments section.
- Thanksgiving is about
loved ones and family
and I must say that we've done
a lotta "Somebody & Lefkoes"
and I love everyone
that I've worked with.
But there is one man
that I just can't quit.
So with three games
on Thanksgiving
it is time to bring Allie back.
It's Thanksgiving.
I had to come home.
- [Laughing]
We've been waiting
for a very long time.
I've gone on a number
of bet dates.
None of them have worked out
and I hear you've been texting
my producer your own game picks.
- Yes.
You been missin' me too,
haven't you?
- Yes, I have, Adam.
- Let's just come in
for the real thing.
Let's come in
- Yes!
That was a really good hug.
Allie's a good hugger.
Here's how this is gonna work.
- OK.
- I have three games on Thursday.
- Three.
You win two of them,
I'm back here next week.
You win one, you win zero,
we gotta go through
this whole thing again
where we don't talk anymore.
- Aww!
- I know.
I don't want that.
- No, no, no.
- You don't want that.
- So let's start off, first game.
- OK.
- Bears go to Detroit.
Bears are favored by 3.5.
- OK.
Gimme your thought process
and your pick.
This is game No. 1.
- That's a division game.
- It is a division game.
- Bears showed up yesterday.
- Boy, did they.
- But Matt Patricia did
a good job against Carolina.
- Yes, he did.
- I still like the Bears.
- First Allie Lock,
goin' Bears.
Second game of the day.
Alex Smith is down.
Colt McCoy steps up.
Washington in Dallas,
Cowboys favored by 7.5.
- In Dallas, Thanksgiving Day?
- In Dallas, Thanksgiving Day.
Jerry Jones sittin' there going,
"I love that Dak Prescott."
- I love it, too.
I think that—
I don't think that Colt McCoy is
gonna do good in Texas' stadium.
- OK.
- I don't think so.
- Colt McCoy did beat the Cowboys
with Washington a few years ago,
but I understand the bet.
I really do.
So you're goin' Chicago,
then you're goin' Dallas.
Last one.
Falcons go to the Saints.
Saints are favored by 13.
- Ooh.
- Thirteen.
- Thirteen points.
- Yes.
- In New Orleans?
- In New Orleans.
Track meet.
- I like the Saints.
- You like the Saints.
- Yeah.
- Allie is going favorite,
favorite, favorite.
Bears, Cowboys, Saints.
And I'm gonna be honest
with you.
- Mhm?
- I probably would've done
the same thing.
- OK.
- I hope I'm back next week.
- I like it.
- His three picks were the Bears,
the Cowboys
and the Saints all to cover.
- Right.
- What do you think?
- Well, what was
the Bears' spread?
- 3.5. Cowboys was 7.5.
Saints were 13.
- I like the Lions to cover it
and keep it close, OK?
- Wow.
- Then there's the—which one?
- Washington is 7.5-point dogs
to Dallas.
- I like Washington to
keep it close as well.
- Wow.
And what about Saints-Falcons?
- And that's what?
- Saints, 13 points.
- I like Atlanta
to keep it close.
- So you're going against Allie
in all three picks.
- Bring it, Allie.
There's only one Oracle
around here.
- I am thankful for Allie,
and because
this is our Thanksgiving
episode, I'm curious.
What else are you thankful for?
- Well, first of all,
I'm thankful for you there—
- Appreciate you, man.
- Good old friendy, old pal.
- And—ohhh!
- I'm thankful for Nate Burleson—
- You're coachable too!
- For teaching me how to do a handshake.
- No, but I'm thankful
for a lot of things.
My family,
the great life that we have
the people that work here
at Bleacher Report.
- Yeah.
It's a special place,
and it's really cool.
- Yeah, I wanna thank everyone
that works on this show.
You guys are amazing.
I wanna thank, really,
to be honest
everyone that's a part of this
"Simms & Lefkoe" community
that tweets at us
and Facebook comments
and Instagram comments
and watches this show.
You guys are amazing.
I know that we're goofs
and we talk
about football every week,
but we appreciate your support.
And thank you to my parents
and my family
and my girlfriend, Inem,
and his wife, Danielle.
- Oh, thank you.
You're winning
a lot of points here.
- That's what I'm tryin' to do.
- Gosh, geez.
- It's awesome.
Thank you, guys, so much.
You're amazing.
Enjoy the games on Thursday.
Enjoy the games on Sunday.
For Simms—
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- And I thank you for doing
that every frickin' episode
cuz you don't have to.
We'll holler at you guys later.
- That's it.
No more after Thanksgiving.
♪♪♪
- It's "hello," too. It's not "HLLHRRRRH!"
- I would add even more draft picks
- Oh!
- To trade to the Raiders
to get Khalil Mack again!
I would spend more—look, I'd trade
those flowers that just
fell over your name!
It's about family.
It's about rekindling.
- [Sneezing]
- It's Chris Simms' sneezes.
- [Laughing]